a brand new space pirate character has
beef with grief in the latest episode of
the Mandalorian but The Man Behind the
Mask is an industry veteran here's what
vayne looks like in real life season 3
of the Mandalorian offers up another
glimpse into the lives of Pedro Pascal's
Den jarin the ever adorable grogu and
plenty of other returning characters but
it also adds quite a few Fresh Faces to
the mix among the newcomers is an
intimidating space pirate named vane a
frequenter of the Navarro Locale vayne
doesn't take kindly to the new direction
of the city after its Liberation from
the hands of the Empire he has also
clearly got a history with grief karga a
plot thread that seems ripe for
expansion in the series future it was
your cut of my boss's treasure that
built this salute Beyond his plot
significance the most striking thing
about vayne is his physical appearance
the space Pirate's face is quite
striking lacking any discernible nose
and sporting horns not too dissimilar
from those on Darth Maul it's such an
out there appearance that viewer may be
shocked to learn what the actor behind
vein looks like when he's not buried
under heaps of Prosthetics the man who
plays vayne is Marty matulis a six foot
four American actor known for his
creature work in horror fantasy and
science fiction matulis has appeared in
a bunch of popular TV shows for decades
though almost invariably as characters
that require heavy Prosthetics or
elaborate costume design back in the
sixth season of American Horror Story
matulis recurred as the Sinister piggy
man a ghost that Sports the giant
severed head of a pig he appeared as
several different monstrous characters
on Teen Wolf and he's occupied a similar
role for the Paramount plus Supernatural
drama evil one of the actor's most high
profile appearances in recent years
however is his role in the 2022 horror
film smile in the movie's climax when
audiences finally get a brief Glimpse at
the true form of the malevolent smile
entity haunting the characters matulis
is the one who brings the Demonic mass
of Flesh and teeth to life all in all
matulis is quietly one of the key
players in the modern landscape of
Horror and sci-fi if anything his
eventual debut into the Canon of Star
Wars through the Mandalorian was
something of an inevitability it also
means he gets to join the distinguished
Club of actors who have appeared in both
Star Trek and Star Wars at one point or
another on an episode of Daniel shirl's
memories of a moon bird podcast matulis
went in depth on how demanding roles
that require heavy Prosthetics can get
telling the host that he typically
Sports a shaved head in face to make for
easier gluing the transformation often
takes hours to complete and matulis of
course has a front row seat I just sit
in a chair looking into a mirror as I
watch these ridiculously talented people
build this creation on top of me even
once the makeup and materials have been
applied Matula says to account for his
altered physicality when giving his
performance he told Cheryl I might have
to put 30 more effort into my angry face
or whatever happens during the scene so
that's my time to figure out how I can
translate myself through the makeup and
make the makeup look alive and not like
a rubber mask it's tough work but Matula
says nevertheless stuck with the job for
more than 20 years as major roles like
vayne and the Mandalorian and the smile
entity and smile demonstrate that
commitment has paid off matula's shared
on the podcast as a younger actor I
thought oh that's really cool but it's
more of a step to do something else now
as a nearly 50 year old kid I adore this
process
foreign